i do believe marshall
was on the set in chicago when
i wore the fedora
that dionne insisted i buy to keep my
head warm in chicago that susie
subliquid subsequently set on fire it
may have been the trip to the stadium
where we stopped off
to get some uh giordano's pizza okay
and
um where i insisted that the bus stop at
the giordano's pizza place and we all
went got it and i think i don't recall
what it was but i think it's
had to do with something where i i
didn't share the pizza or didn't get for
everybody i just got for myself like i
called and i had it
i had it pre-ordered and i just went and
picked it up so that's karma for the
time that we did it to you i think
marshall
marshall then i think i think marshall
spent the entire
excursion to the stadium giving me crap
for not
ordering for everybody wait a minute
you're in the moment with everybody
[Laughter]
pre-ordered the pizza and then i went
and grabbed it and i just had it was on
my own personal pizza hey guys i'll be
right back i just gotta hop off the bus
for a second
interesting i made the entire box so you
made the bus stop make a stop
that's what marshall spent i mean he was
well you know marshall like he just
likes to be on me about stuff that he
knows is getting in my skull
is he on hold hearing all this right
yeah yeah yeah
damn it
you made a whole bus stop i mean you
didn't share it
get over what do you mean half the bus i
said the whole bus you made the whole
bus stop well there was probably about
like you know it was like a one like
quote-unquote party bus not like a
school bus you know it's like one of
those buses yeah there's like 10 12
seats on it
and so not quite like six of it was like
six of us and i'm like guys i'm your
mind we're gonna stop at your donors i
already ordered a pizza it's really
ready
great i thought i thought it was uh me
pre-ordering was saving everyone time
it's no big deal to stop it was on the
way yeah but when you say i order the
pizza i'm sitting there thinking oh rich
got pizza for his bed why would i do
that it was like three in the afternoon
i was the only idiot who didn't have
lunch
i'm just saying
[Laughter]
back here in the terrestrial radio
program uh for those who are listening
terrestrially boy
we just delivered a setup for this
conversation my pro football hall of
fame friend who i love dearly um is
marshall falk here on the rich eisen
show on the mercedes-benz vans phone
line how are you marshall
rich i am doing good man
i am doing very well excellent and this
holiday spin this holiday season
and yes i was on hold
i want you guys to know i don't just
give rich you know
crap for nothing
just imagine we're on our way
to talk about the ultimate team sport
and our quarterback our leader
stops the van
with a few other hall of famers played
the ultimate team sport
to pick up a pizza
that was a personal thing
that is insane
four
personal slices
i mean
we were okay with stopping the bus
because we thought that
he was go like rich got pizza for
awesome
he came out with a pan a personal size
pizza
and i proceeded for the next
six and a half hours to remind him of
his efforts
[Music]
yeah
he's a team player
confirmed confirmed
by marshall faulk himself right
oh gosh
oh wow that happened
would say my bad that happened in
chicago illinois that did happen oh man
oh my god good time though oh yes oh yes
but your favorite i'll just let you keep
going if you wish your favorite is the
uh the coat rack
in new orleans in in new england
he's already laughing he's laughing we
were
we're in
and so within the small trailer i am
sitting extremely close to rich
like leg touching
[Laughter]
and he tries
he he he's upset that is that he's a
small space we don't have any we can't
move around and he's trying to like find
somewhere to put his coat
oh my god they've had this they took
somebody some one of the pas built this
coat rack and it just
[Laughter]
everybody else is just trying to stay
warm because we haven't gone out in new
england yet and it's like 20 degrees and
we're in this little box okay in a
parking lot
right
because cause probably yeah cause there
was no you know there was no room i
guess in all of
foxborough for us to be placed
you know to do this thing and so
marshall sensed my anxiety over the
whole situation and marshall there was
enough space for you to not touch me you
kept nudging you kept nudging
next to me you kept on shoving me you
kept on so i couldn't even write like i
couldn't even type because you just kept
on
and then i would look at you like can
you give me some space and then you just
kept looking at me like
yeah no no no
another person could have fit on that
couch
but i just i i wanted to be close to you
let's do it
i wanted to be in your hospital space
but here's what i am going to say yes
the next year when we went back to new
england they had an actual room for us
they did so as we say squeaky
[Music]
marshall nick made me squeaky
you are squeaky that was my that was my
nickname for marshall the squeaky wheel
rich squeaky little guys we used to have
um we used to have on set we had
snickers bars from whenever we were
just want everyone to understand that
that's not the way i always am the
snicker bar was the indication that
that's not reeling me
no no no but but there's there's those
moments where um
everything everything will just it just
it'll just pile up on him and he and he
has to say
something like he'll hold it in he can
deal with it he can deal with it and i
can see it i i can sense it on his face
and i'm like oh
i just got it i just got to get him
there i got to get him to the boiling
point so here's the best part about this
conversation then we'll talk a little
bit actual football is the reason why
we're having this conversation is
because the kurt warner silver puffy
jacket that that trended on twitter
all night
on monday night so many text messages
what's your boy wearing
and you know he's sensitive about it you
know deep down he's a little sensitive
about it no doubt no doubt right but i
think i think it was a great i think i i
believe yes um it was a great marketing
ploy by lionsgate
to get kurt to wear the jacket to have
him trending
in time with the movie yes
there's
think about it
think about it it's like when justin
bieber is about to release an album he
goes to jail
so the silver jacket is the jail of the
equation it's what you're saying
it makes so much sense now i'm crying
this is so funny
oh everybody out there in america just
go watch courage movies yes you should
it is
it is beautiful it's a beautiful movie
you know and uh
and and the guy who plays ray lewis was
that was that
that guy was great because that was the
you know that was the what was that like
the first game though the first because
in the movie just so everyone knows you
do see kurt's first game spoiler alert
he does make the rams in start and it's
against the ravens what was that like
that day first game against ray and the
ravens
so so literally rich that was the birth
of
that defense and what they became
like that that game was like our first
game becoming
the greatest sean turk and that defense
becoming what they what they were
like that was the game
and and you can tell it was like man
there were some intense plays
some thrills that kurt made in that game
that was the deciding factor in that
game now
we end up winning the super bowl a year
later they win a super right right so it
was it was it was
that that defense
i mean
they were good i mean you could not have
a tougher uh you know a tougher task as
a for a first starting game
and um
some of those throws man somewhat like
that that game
it was it was so impactful in kurt's
career for
what was to come
and and i and and i just loved how he
handled it because it didn't it didn't
start off the way you wanted to start
off and and it was it was exactly as it
was think about this the year before so
in 98 i go into
baltimore and
give it to the ravens i i had about
maybe 250 yards so we were playing them
they were like he's not beating him
right this number 13 is gonna have to do
it so they basically they they put it
all along kurt and i just love how he
handled it yeah i know how he handled it
and he got picked by ray i love how he
handled it he got picked by ray so what
was it like for you guys when you were
thinking okay we do have a great offense
and here's kurt warner who's getting
ripped non-stop in practice you know
i'm gonna be
and this is we didn't have a great offer
we did not know what we had
we had only played one preseason game
with kurt as the starter
going into the opener
so we didn't know
what we were
the confidence wasn't as a team
like individually isaac knew he could do
uh tory coming in at the sixth pick
overall um we knew we had a pretty good
offensive line with that left side of
adam timmerman and orlando pace um and
then and then me
it was that was like that was that was
what our offense consisted of as far as
names went
but
to do what would we develop into as a
team
which we did at we didn't know at that
time
we we had no idea and i must say as much
as people look at what was around kurt
uh
all of the things that you saw it's
still funny i mean
so
i don't know if you people used to
always talk about it was like oh my god
he will stand in the pocket and take the
hit he will stand in the pocket and take
the hit
to watch the movie
and i'm not going to give it away to
watch the movie and find out why right
before why
it's so impactful man i i i like out
that was that was more of a tearjerker
than anything for me because you know
it's like it's like distance travel
what he had to do and
how he turned the weakness into a
strength
i love that dude man me too me too me
too and and um you know that's why
everyone should see the movie and
conversely why it's such a shame he wore
that jacket
um and so uh tj came up tell marshall
your idea of the jacket and then we'll
talk a little football with them so yeah
go for it well marshall you know
everyone was cracking on kurt about his
jacket right and then i said yesterday
the only
jacket color kurt warner cares about is
a gold jacket and then it hit me what if
the pro football hall of fame gave you
guys jackets for different weather
conditions so you get your blazer right
but then if it's raining like carol
carmichael yesterday you have a
hall of fame like raincoat then you have
a pea coat when it's cold maybe a
windbreaker when the weather's you know
chilly cold puffy cold you know just
give you guys different jackets for
different weather occasions what do you
think
i i i actually think it's great let's
just um either
maybe nike says they're the lead sponsor
maybe burlington coat factory
they could just produce the coach yeah
right for different i think it's a great
idea
it's awesome yeah right so at a game
like that at a game that kurt's calling
he could sit there with his hall of fame
jacket on that you know for wichita
triple fat goose stay warm
i think it's a great idea i think it's a
great and you've got yeah someone's
going to get rich off of this and it
ain't going to be me no no right
right and i think when it's cold you you
give another option
right and then you look inside and you
put your number inside what's your
number what's your hall of fame number
265. so you put 265 in the in and it's
all authentic only only those gentlemen
who said that niche luncheon can get
these jackets of course it's still you
know
an elite club but you know they get you
covered for any type of weather they go
so i'll bring this up i'll bring this up
at the next committee meeting we have
for hall of fame
this is what i love about the hall of
fame
if i if i if i go out and find the
sponsor to do it then they're all for it
like they don't just turn stuff down
when we give ideas because this is a
great idea i'm gonna be honest with you
this is a great idea for you know
football is the inclement weather sport
football is famous we get to this time
yeah
i think it's a great idea there you go
seriously and that's there you go from
hall of famer number two six five number
two eight on your program the marshall
565 and the hall of fame bus gallery
there you go telling you all right also
marshall don't sell yourself short in 98
against baltimore you had 267 total
yards
he was a bad man
i'm never perfect with the numbers when
they're mine
i always round down just to give people
an opportunity
you're a humble guy you're a humble man
you're a humble man with a plan
uh so uh cooper cup just passed isaac
bruce's uh team record for most
receptions in a season they got three
games to go
how far do you think this rams team can
go marshall fall what do you got for me
um
uh i'm gonna say this
uh defensively
i feel like rahim morris is doing a
great job at at putting these pieces
together you know he got he had some
guys and convincing them to play as a
team two
two games ago
when i was listening to the announcer it
was like oh yeah the rams have these
individual pieces but on defense they
have to learn how to play together and
connect it
and you you know you know warren's app
will tell you more that's all sap used
to talk about front and in the back end
we got to work together and and for a
while you know when they were on that
that losing streak they weren't playing
together defensively
and and and i i think that what we're
starting to see now which is
you can't just double aaron donald
and and then chip floyd
and what von miller is doing and and the
young defensive backs
you know two weeks ago
no ramsey how they stepped up you know
and it
i i was i am impressed that what i see
defensively now offensively
it's all there
it's all there i'm i hate to call people
out
center got hurt they put the other
center in running game looks really good
i think that you know
the backup center is a better center i
don't get to make those decisions and
then you know rich i i've been saying it
since they since they got it it all
comes down to the number nine
you know it all comes down to number
nine and we're we're gonna find out
there's there's times we can blame it on
detroit as a franchise and there's times
we can see
matthew stafford was the reason the
stuff was going on in detroit and it's
the same it's the same with the rams you
know when when he's on point
and um he threw some dimes the other
night like i'm talking about in traffic
throws that have to be made they got to
be put in certain spots no matter how
strong your arm is or or you have to be
accurate he was accurate there's times
that hasn't happened this season
and as this lead goes you're going to
find out he's going to go up against tom
brady he's going to go up against aaron
rodgers and they're not going to make a
lot of mistakes
and the question is
you know can can he make
more plays and less mistakes than them
has it been in his dna but he didn't
have a sean mcveigh so
can't wait for it man
can i wait for it marshall faulk on the
state of the los angeles rams one of the
greatest rams of all time right here on
the rich eisen show before i let you go
you got any uh two cents on urban meyer
all that stuff
[Laughter]
hey rich you know man i'm not gonna kick
him in while he's down you know um
when they hired him and you people they
got on me i i asked a simple question
and you know i i just was like how do
you hire a guy
um when you look at everywhere he's been
he eventually he stepped down
uh eventually that's going to happen and
i just wanted to know
if if if i'm hiring a college coach
cliff pisbury has developed talent
at the quarterback position so i can
understand arizona i just didn't get the
urban meyer higher for the young
quarterback i just didn't get it
he
all the great teams that he had from
florida
ohio state
he had alex smith
as his only quarterback
starting in the nfl
and that said something to me um i just
couldn't trust him to develop
the first overall pick
so
uh
i i didn't expect for it to go that way
i just felt that you know it he he
wouldn't turn around but all the turmoil
all the things that we're hearing stuff
that's coming out now
um just not good i i i think that he's
you know he's
gonna
he's served with time he's put in the
work um i just hate to see it go this
way rich but um
i told you so
i i i i hear you marshall i i thought
the mini didn't get on that plane in
cincinnati whether the team knew about
it or not or okayed it or not the minute
he didn't get on that plane to go home
it was a wrap i said that here
right over
when that happened and then obviously
i don't even know how you do not get on
that plane i don't even understand i
don't like i can't even i like
i i can't even
you can be on that plane and take a
private jet back
right but i don't know how you don't get
on that plane
the minute i saw that and then of course
the you know what happened when when he
stayed behind it just was
the end of that yeah i don't even want
to get the man's personal stuff right
what happened you know
crap happens but but not getting on that
plane
that was the that that was the deciding
factor what happened after you know that
that that doesn't matter but not getting
on that plane you do not not get on the
plane with your team that's just that
that's unheard of
it's unheard of
so just to wrap everything up we just
heard your your two cents on urban uh
you're concerned about uh stafford's
ability to win when chips are down uh
because he you need to see it to to
i mean it was a stat about him
not winning against teams with winning
records right it was some crazy stat i
was just sitting there like
wow
right
it blew me away
we were talking about it once before it
was some crazy stat
of of his record versus teams that was
above 500 right
so there's that uh go see kurt's movie
um
um you're into the idea of the hall of
fame making a hall of fame jacket for
different weather types so kurt can
can uh not trend and you can stay warm
um
and
um
my bad on not getting everyone pizza in
chicago that time oh did you do you
remember the time i wore that fedora
because that was we were talking
yesterday about about about fashion
choices that you thought were good but
the rest of the world did not because of
what happened with curt remember that
fedora i wore that dion told me to buy
and
what do you think when i showed up with
the fedora marshall for real um you know
susie and i we agreed
we share the same intimate we we we love
you we both love you and we want what's
best for you
we're here for you thank you marshall
appreciate it you take care happy
holidays merry christmas to everyone in
your world i love you too that's
marshall everybody hall of famer oh my
gosh
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here